Muy buenas tardes
primero quitarle un poco de credibilidad
a las encuestas y sobre todo la decadem
porque sabemos Por quienes Por qué
personeros políticos está manejada esta
esta empresa que hace encuestas la
muestra es muy pequeña
no son más de dos mil encuestas de un
total de Diez mil de diez millones de
personas que estamos habilitadas para
votar en Chile Por eso yo le quito un
poco de legitimidad a esta encuesta y
no lo veo tan así
Bueno alejándonos un poco de las
encuestas sigue siendo Boris visto como
esta figura del pueblo con esa imagen
con la que llegó a alcanzar la
presidencia o se percibe ahora como
parte del establishment
no sigue siendo percibido y valorado su
actitud cercana de un presidente
cercano con la gente con el pueblo
creo que esto no se ha perdido creo que
eso más bien ha ido creciendo porque a
medida que él ha desarrollado su mandato
ha dado pruebas en terreno de esta de
esto que le digo
Cuáles creen que ha sido sus mayores
desafíos en el último año
yo creo que puntualmente ahora y es el
tema de
los indultos
también todas las medidas económicas que
van a tener que implementarse para
poder
coordinar de mejor forma económica que
se viene a nivel mundial
ahora señora ofen salida estamos
hablando de sus primeros 10 meses en el
cargo todavía le quedan otros años más
Cómo podría mejorar el panorama para
Borges y en qué debe concentrarse
bueno él debe concentrarse en atender
las demandas sociales del pueblo que él
no se aleje de esta
de este que tiene él y es un presidente
cercano que de soluciones
a temas de seguridad pública también
porque estamos con
con una fuerte crisis de seguridad
pública
yo creo que eso seguridad pública el
tema de la cercanía que no se pierda de
un presidente en terreno
bien y ver Andrea fue en salida analista
política Gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en las 24